>> Will Sentance: Đó là bản chất công việc nguyên mẫu tuyệt vời của chúng tôi là những công việc màu tím
dòng, bản chất nguyên mẫu của JavaScript.
Đó là một cách rất hay để đảm bảo rằng chúng tôi không
phải có mức tăng trực tiếp trên người dùng 1 và người dùng 2 và người dùng 500.
Nhưng chúng tôi có quyền truy cập vào nó bởi vì khi chúng tôi không tìm thấy sự gia tăng trên thảm
trên bản thân đối tượng JavaScript không hoảng sợ.
Có vẻ như nó là thuộc tính proto trong 1, hướng đến nơi nó liên kết với chức năng của người dùng
lưu trữ và tìm một phiên bản đã lưu duy nhất của hàm đó, lấy và sử dụng nó.
Chúng tôi yêu nó.
Nhưng như tôi đã nói, nó liên quan khá nhiều đến việc viết mã.
Vì vậy, nếu chúng ta nhìn lại, chúng ta đã tạo đối tượng theo cách thủ công bằng object.create,
lưu trữ trong một người dùng mới.
Chẳng qua, tạm thời chỉ là một cái tên thôi, bọn họ không bao giờ vướng bận cái tên đó.
Trả lại đối tượng đó theo cách thủ công, chúng tôi cũng đã viết mã cho đối tượng đó.
Tạo liên kết để sử dụng một cửa hàng chức năng.
Sẽ thật tuyệt nếu chúng ta có thể tự động hóa những thứ đó phải không?
Và bạn biết những gì?
Sẽ có một từ khóa, tôi sẽ sử dụng màu xanh lam cho nó, nhưng
Tôi sẽ chèn trước khi chạy chức năng của mình, mọi người từ khóa đó là gì?
Vì tôi đã viết ra rồi mà tôi không nên có, nó là gì?
>> Braden: Mới.
>> Will Sentance: Mới, tốt lắm mọi người.
Xin lỗi, [SOUND] mới và tại sao nếu chúng tôi nói đó là [SOUND] mới,
thú vị, tôi sẽ nói từ đó và
mọi người sẽ tự động hóa rất nhiều thứ cho chúng ta.
Nó sẽ tự động tạo bên trong đây một đối tượng.
Vì vậy, mọi thứ có màu xanh lam sẽ là những thứ sẽ được thực hiện cho
chúng tôi theo từ khóa mới.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi không phải làm điều đó, chúng tôi không phải viết mã đó nữa.
Nó sẽ tự động tạo một đối tượng mới cho chúng ta.
Nó sẽ tự động trả lại đối tượng đó cho chúng ta.
Vâng,
>> Will Sentance: Đó cũng là, tin rằng nó hoặc
không, nó sẽ tạo liên kết đến một số đối tượng có đầy đủ các chức năng ở đây,
tự động cho chúng tôi.
Cũng sẽ đặt thuộc tính proto tự động cho chúng tôi.
Tôi sẽ nói điều này, chúng ta có thể nghĩ đến đâu?
Bởi vì, hãy chờ đợi, trước khi chúng tôi đặt đối tượng đó theo cách thủ công mà chúng tôi đã tìm kiếm một người dùng mới
có thuộc tính proto ẩn được liên kết để sử dụng một cửa hàng chức năng đã có ở đó.
Nhưng bây giờ tôi nghĩ sẽ là trường hợp.
Vì vậy, tôi không biết chúng tôi sẽ đặt các chức năng cửa hàng được chia sẻ của mình ở đâu nếu không
trong cửa hàng chức năng của người dùng, chúng tôi sẽ không tự mình kiểm soát nữa.
Một điều khác là, làm thế nào tôi có thể đặt các thuộc tính trên đối tượng này?
Tôi đã ánh xạ nhãn gì để có thể truy cập đối tượng này và
dính các đặc tính vào nó.
Tôi đã cho nó nhãn gì?
>> Braden: Người dùng mới.
>> Will Sentance: Nếu đối tượng đó đang được tạo tự động cho chúng tôi,
tôi có thể gán cho nó một nhãn không?
Không.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi có một vài câu hỏi, chúng tôi sẽ liên kết đến đâu?
Và đối tượng này sẽ tự động được đưa ra làm nhãn là gì?
Tôi hy vọng nó không phải là nhãn giống như chúng tôi có
một cái gì đó khác trong các lệnh gọi hàm khác, điều đó sẽ hơi ngớ ngẩn, phải không?
Vâng, chúng tôi sẽ không muốn, chẳng hạn như chúng tôi sẽ không muốn nói rằng,
điều này mà ở một nơi khác đề cập đến một cái gì đó hoàn toàn khác.
Điều đó sẽ rất điên rồ.
Được rồi, mọi người, vì vậy từ khóa mới tự động hóa công việc khó khăn.
Khi chúng ta gọi hàm trả về một đối tượng,
với từ khóa mới phía trước, chúng tôi tự động hóa 2 việc.
Trước hết, chúng tôi tạo đối tượng tự động.
Sau đó, chúng tôi thấy tôi đã đặt cái mới trước nó.
Sau đó, chúng tôi trả lại đối tượng tự động.
Trong khi chờ đợi, chúng tôi đảm bảo rằng chúng tôi sẽ gắn những thứ trong đó.
Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta cần điều chỉnh cách chúng ta viết phần thân của hàm này, userCreator,
mã của nó.
Làm cách nào chúng ta có thể tham khảo đối tượng được tạo tự động này và
biết nơi đặt các phiên bản đơn lẻ của chúng tôi, một trong các phiên bản của các chức năng được chia sẻ?
Bởi vì tôi không được chọn đặt nó vào một thứ gì đó
được gọi là cửa hàng chức năng người dùng nữa.
Phần đầu tiên chúng ta có thể trả lời ngay bây giờ, hãy đoán.
Bạn nghĩ sao họ gọi đối tượng này là đối tượng được tạo ra tự động bất kỳ ai lấy
một đoán, Peter?
>> Braden: Có >> Will Sentance: Có,
cái này chính xác sẽ được gọi là cái này.
Cho rằng điều này đề cập đến đối tượng nhất định duy nhất của nó hoặc
một giai đoạn khác của đối tượng đó.
Sau đó, khi chúng ta chạy tăng dần trên đối tượng và trong góc thực thi của nó,
là điều này đề cập đến bất kỳ đối tượng nào ở bên trái dấu chấm,
chúng hoàn toàn tách biệt.
Điều đó hơi khó hiểu khi chúng tôi đọc mã của mình,
không chỉ một chút, nó sâu sắc khó hiểu.
Đây là quy tắc quan trọng khác về cách hoạt động của nó.
Nó luôn luôn là bất cứ thứ gì đối tượng ở bên trái dấu chấm khi chúng ta chạy một phương thức,
rằng điều này được gán ngầm cho người dùng 1.
Nó có một vai trò khác, nếu chúng ta sử dụng từ khóa mới, đối tượng được tạo tự động
bên trong ngữ cảnh thực thi đó sẽ gắn nhãn này, nhưng chúng hoàn toàn tách biệt.
Được rồi, chúng ta sẽ đưa ra một phiên bản đã lưu duy nhất của hàm chúng ta muốn ở đâu,
tất cả các đối tượng đến từ việc thực thi?
Đây là những cách thực thi hoàn toàn khác nhau của người tạo người dùng, chúng tôi muốn tất cả
những chức năng được chia sẻ mà các đối tượng này có liên kết để được lưu trữ?
Để hiểu được điều đó, chúng ta cần thêm một đoạn mở đầu ưu việt nữa,
chúng ta hãy có một cái nhìn.
Prelude ưu việt, trước khi chúng tôi làm điều đó,
từ khóa mới tự động hóa rất nhiều công việc thủ công của chúng tôi.
Bạn thấy chúng tôi loại bỏ việc tạo đối tượng sẽ được thực hiện cho
chúng tôi với chìa khóa mới.
Khi chúng tôi chạy, người dùng được tạo mới sẽ chèn và
nó sẽ tự động dán dòng đó lên đó,
tạo một đối tượng mới sẽ cố gắng làm điều này không phải với người dùng mới.
Sau đó, chúng tôi sẽ có quyền truy cập vào đối tượng đó bằng cách sử dụng điều này.
Chúng tôi sẽ không làm newUser.name nữa.
Chúng tôi sẽ đặt tên này để sửa chữa những thứ trong đó.
Và nó sẽ tự động trả lại đối tượng này thành người dùng 1.
Nhưng cửa hàng chức năng của chúng tôi, kết nối của chúng tôi với cửa hàng chức năng đã hoàn thành và biến mất ngay bây giờ.
Vậy chúng ta sẽ đi đâu?
Chúng tôi cần một đồ vật cũ lớn mà chúng tôi có thể chắc chắn rằng với sự giúp đỡ của họ,
với một từ khóa mới, đối tượng được tạo tự động,
thuộc tính proto của nó sẽ liên kết với một số đối tượng.
Tôi cần biết nơi đó sẽ đến.
Để biết nó sẽ ở đâu, chúng ta hãy xem đoạn kết nhỏ này.
Hàm vừa là đối tượng vừa là hàm trong JavaScript.
Chúng tôi cần nó ở đây, mọi người.
Một chút bổ sung ở đây, thực sự quan trọng để chúng tôi hiểu.
Vì vậy, chúng ta có, bộ nhớ, bạn biết đấy,
hãy làm một, >> Will Sentance: Một chút công việc.
Vâng, hãy nhìn vào điều đó dựa trên
lời khuyên từ một trong những khán giả của chúng tôi.
Vậy dòng 1 ở đây, Dan, chúng ta đang làm gì trong trí nhớ?
>> Dan: Chúng tôi đang lưu trữ hàm NhânBy2.
>> Will Sentance: Ừ, hãy lưu trữ hàm nhânBy2, nó đây.
Được rồi, dòng 2 Jeff, chúng ta đang làm gì ở dòng đó?
>> Jeff: Chúng tôi đang tạo một cửa hàng tài sản trên MultiBy2,
>> Will Sentance: Nhưng đó là một chức năng,
trừ khi Jeff?
>> Jeff: Đó là một đồ vật.
>> Will Sentance: Một hàm cộng với một đối tượng.
Hóa ra ngay sau khi JavaScript nhìn thấy hàm từ khóa đó,
biết một chức năng đang đến,
chúng ta nhận được một hàm cộng, >> Will Sentance: A big
vật cũ đính kèm.
Nếu chúng ta sử dụng parens ở cuối hàm, chúng ta sẽ thấy sau một giây.
Nếu chúng ta sử dụng dấu chấm ở cuối nhãn hàm, nhãn cho
chức năng, bit nào chúng ta có quyền truy cập vào Jeff?
>> Jeff: Đó là gì?
>> Will Sentance: Nếu chúng ta sử dụng dấu chấm ở cuối nhãn MultiBy2,
bit nào của tổ hợp đối tượng hàm.
Tôi gọi họ, chúng ta có bit nào?
Chúng tôi có quyền truy cập vào bit đối tượng, chính xác thông qua dấu chấm, vào nó chúng tôi đi.
Và chúng ta sẽ lưu trữ gì trong đó, Braden?
>> Braden: 5.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, tên tài sản nào?
>> Braden: Đã lưu trữ.
>> Will Sentance: Đã lưu trữ, nhìn này, tuyệt vời.
Nhưng có lẽ, hãy nhìn vào dòng tiếp theo,
có thể khi sau đó chúng ta chạy MultiBy2 với đầu vào là 3.
Có thể điều đó không hoạt động nữa vì có thể việc làm này đã ghi đè hàm
mã, phải không Braden?
Không, điều gì cho phép chúng tôi bây giờ vẫn sử dụng hàm bit,
những biểu tượng chúng tôi đang sử dụng ở đây?
>> Braden: Các parens.
>> Will Sentance: Parens, và điều đó có nghĩa là hãy sử dụng hàm bit,
nó sẽ trở lại 6.
Nhưng có thể việc sử dụng hàm bị ghi đè đối tượng, có thể.
Braden liệu chúng ta vẫn có quyền truy cập vào đối tượng của mình nếu chúng ta sử dụng ký hiệu dấu chấm?
>> Braden: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, chúng tôi làm.
Đối tượng hàm và chúng ta đang nói về một đối tượng nhiều như nhau, nhưng
nó có trong mọi chức năng ở đó.
Nhưng nó sẽ hóa ra ở đây là siêu, siêu, siêu hữu ích.
Nhưng nếu bạn muốn tin rằng tất cả các chức năng cũng sẽ có,
rất hay ở chỗ tất cả các chức năng cũng có theo mặc định.
>> Braden: Nguyên mẫu?
>> Will Sentance: A, tôi không muốn nói điều đó.
Một tài sản, không, vâng, đó là những gì, nhưng a, không, vâng, họ có, trời ơi, vâng.
Chúng tôi sẽ thấy điều đó, mặc dù bạn sẽ thấy điều đó ở sảnh OOP tạm dừng.
Chuyên môn hóa OOP Habert, nhưng quan trọng hơn đối với chúng tôi ngay bây giờ, họ có một tài sản.
Không có gì kỳ diệu, khi bạn nhìn thấy nguyên mẫu tài liệu,
chúng tôi nghĩ, có thể có một số loại tiền thưởng kỳ diệu trong tất cả những điều đó.
Đó là thuộc tính của một đối tượng và tên của thuộc tính là gì Braden?
>> Braden: MultiplyBy2.
>> Will Sentance: Không hoàn toàn, Peter, tên của tài sản là?
>> Peter: Nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Nguyên mẫu.
Chính xác, thuộc tính đó chỉ là nguyên mẫu và o.
Đây là nơi ta cảm thấy thú vị.
Tất cả các chức năng trong định dạng đối tượng của chúng luôn tự động có
một tài sản trên chúng.
Ý tôi là, tại sao dấu chấm chấm chấm, thực ra nó tự động ở đó,
nguyên mẫu?
Nó không phải là một tài sản ẩn.
Nó giống như một thuộc tính của bit đối tượng.
Chúng tôi chỉ không có xu hướng nhìn vào điều này một chút.
Chúng tôi cần phải điều khiển nhiều nhật ký bằng cách nhấn xuống một chút.
Ý tôi là, tôi đoán những đồ vật được giấu với chúng ta và nó ở đó.
Nó là gì?
Dan, thuộc tính nguyên mẫu được mặc định là gì?
>> Dan: Vật thể trống rỗng.
>> Will Sentance: Một vật thể trống rỗng lớn.
Nhìn kìa.
Có nghĩa là, hàm mà chúng ta sẽ sử dụng hàm mới khi nó được thực thi và
nó tự động tạo ra một đối tượng rất cần một nơi để liên kết đến,
một đối tượng trống lớn cũ, trong đó để lưu trữ các chức năng của chúng tôi với chúng tôi để lưu trữ các chức năng.
Chức năng đó không chỉ là một chức năng, nó còn là một cái gì vậy Jeff?
>> Jeff: Một đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Một đối tượng.
Và đối tượng đó không rỗng, nó có gì trong đó?
>> Jeff: Một tài sản nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Một nguyên mẫu được đặt đúng cách, độc đáo, đó là gì, Mark?
>> Matt: Một vật thể trống rỗng lớn.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi nghĩ dân gian rằng nó có thể có ý nghĩa ở đâu
chúng tôi có từ khóa mới hoặc cho
JavaScript đã quyết định các từ khóa mới đối tượng được tạo tự động bên trong
việc chạy của người dùng Tạo một hàm để nó có giao thức
kết nối là nếu nó không thể chỉ định rằng chức năng người dùng của nó lưu trữ?
Matt, bạn nghĩ nó có ý nghĩa ở chỗ nào?
>> Matt: Thuộc tính nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Thuộc tính nguyên mẫu của hàm mà chúng ta sẽ chạy
từ khóa mới hoặc chúng tôi sẽ chạy với từ khóa mới để từ khóa đó tạo ra
một đối tượng tự động bên trong.
Và điều đó sẽ có một ràng buộc đối với tài sản proto của nó với
thuộc tính nguyên mẫu đó, là một đối tượng.
Giao thức sẽ không liên kết để sử dụng cửa hàng chức năng, nhưng
liên kết đến đối tượng này.
Vì vậy, tốt hơn chúng ta nên đặt các hàm mà chúng ta muốn tất cả các đối tượng thoát ra
tự động hoặc đến với người dùng đang chạy được tạo bằng từ khóa mới phía trước
tự động tạo một đối tượng, đối tượng này cần một nơi nào đó có liên kết đến
các chức năng được chia sẻ của nó.
Chúng sẽ tự động trở thành chức năng tạo đối tượng với
sự trợ giúp của từ khóa mới trong phiên bản đối tượng của nó,
trong thuộc tính nguyên mẫu của nó, bản thân nó là một đối tượng.